-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Chelsea Handler.
And you're gonna shoot this
as a special,
which is very exciting.
-Yes, in Nashville,
June 10th at the Ryman.
We have two shows.
You can get tickets
for the second show
at chelseahandler.com.
And Jo Koy's directing
my special.
-That's really exciting.
And I think it's very important
where you pick
to shoot a special.
Obviously, you've been
almost everywhere.
You have a good sense for what
audiences respond to you best.
So, is a Nashville place
that you've always had,
historically, great shows?
-Yeah, I love Nashville.
That's just a great vibe,
good energy.
You know,
all the Southern cities
that have those, like,
you know, fun, like, pockets
of progressiveness
-- you know, what I mean? --
where people are a little bit --
I mean, I just did a show
in Birmingham, Alabama.
-I've done Birmingham.
It's great.
-It was one of the best shows
I've ever had, and
I was dreading going there.
I was like, "Oh, I'm gonna
get shot," you know?
-Yeah.
You had to cancel some shows,
during your tours,
for health reasons.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, thank you
for bringing that up, Seth.
-You're welcome.
-I --
-And I remember you told me
this was -- you said
it was confidential.
That's right. Keep going. Yeah.
-Uh, yeah.
I had this heart --
it's called a cardiomyopathy.
And I guess a lot of women
between the ages of 40 and 50
have been experiencing this
lately.
But I went onstage, and
I had this chest tightening.
And then, after this,
after my show,
I had a lot of friends there,
agents, managers,
blah, blah, blah.
Everyone went out to a bar,
and it was the first time
I've ever said no to that.
-Wow.
-I didn't feel right.
I was like, "Something's off."
And I went into the hospital
the next day,
and they're like, "Oh, you've
had a cardiomyopathy,"
which just means, like, your
heart feels like it got punched.
And it's recoverable.
90% of people recover,
which I've already recovered.
But, yeah, it was scary.
I was like, "Oh, my God,
all my hard living
is finally catching up to me."
I'm like, "This is it.
I'm gonna pass away tonight."
And my sister was like,
"Oh, my God, did you have
a heart attack?"
I'm like, "I think I had
a heart attack."
The doctor's like, "You did not
have a heart attack."
So, it's a cardiomyopathy.
You can Google it.
[ Laughter ]
-After you Google "Jake."
-Yeah, yeah, after you
Google my nephew.
But you know what?
The doctor said something
really funny to me.
Well, not --
More poignant than funny.
He was -- He said to me,
He said, "Isn't your whole --"
He goes, "I'm not really
familiar with you.
I mean, I know who you are,
but isn't your whole schtick,
like, not to take yourself
too seriously?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And he goes, "Well, maybe
you should take your own advice,
'cause it's stress-induced."
And I was like, "Wow."
I was like, "You're right.
Maybe I do need to
take my own advice.
I am taking myself
too seriously."
-Well, that's very --
It's nice when a doctor
can impart wisdom like that.
That's a wonderful thing.
-I mean, it is their job.
-Yeah, that's true.
-So, yeah.
-That's great.
Yeah, let's not put him
on a pedestal, doctor --
doctor who saved
Chelsea's life.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, I wish
I could remember his name.
I'd give him a shout-out, too,
but, you know,
just focus on Jake.
[ Light laughter ]
-I know you take medicine
very seriously,
except I also know for a fact
that you've taken
some of your dog's medicine.
-I -- Well...
[ Laughter ]
Wow. This is like
you read my diary.
-I think you put this
in a book, though.
-Well, my dog and I
were on a trip in Spain.
-Yeah.
-And my dog
was a great traveler.
He's no longer with us,
not because of what I did
to him, but...
He was a great traveler.
And I decided he needed to
start traveling internationally
as a reward.
And so we went to Spain
with my family.
And I have a sister-in-law
that's pretty annoying.
[ Laughter ]
And I was -- And she's very --
Just in the sense
that she's very overprotective
over my nephews.
Like, she puts sunblock
all over their faces.
Like, she'd put it in their
mouths if she could.
And they're, like,
18-year-old boys.
Like, it's embarrassing
at a certain point.
It's like, "Get off of them.
You're embarrassing me."
And anyway, we were sailing,
and one day I just
couldn't take it anymore.
I was like, "I have to jump
off the boat," you know?
And I swam to shore --
not unlike Julia Roberts
in "Sleeping With the Enemy."
-Yeah.
-And I swam to shore,
and I went in my house,
and my Aunt was standing there,
and she goes,
"What's the matter?
You can't take --"
you know, my sister-in-law --
"anymore?"
I go, "No, she's
driving me crazy."
And she said, "Well, you know,
this doggy medicine
that you got for the dog is
basically like doggy Xanax,
which is real Xanax."
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Great, give it to me."
Like, "That'll
take the edge off."
So I took those, you know,
electively
for the rest of the trip.
-Okay.
-Just to temper my, you know,
temper.
I have a bad --
I have a bad reaction
to people that annoy me.
-Yeah.
-And but then,
when we got on the trip back,
I realized I had taken
all of my dog's medicine
to get him back to the States."
-'Cause he needs it
for a flight.
-He needed it for the flight.
-Gotcha.
-So the flight was
a real hot mess.
[ Laughter ]
-And when I woke up --
Well, I was woken up by one of
the flight attendants,
who told me that my dog
was running around
the first-class area,
and that I needed to wake up.
And it was -- It was
a [Bleep] show at the end.
I was convinced,
as soon as we landed
and got back to LAX,
I was like,
"Oh, they're gonna arrest me,"
like, "Animal Services
are coming to get me,
and they're gonna arrest me,
and they're gonna
take my dog away."
And so they didn't.
Everything worked out fine.
I mean, I've never flown
that airline again.
[ Laughter ]
Not because it was bad.
I just thought, they've met
enough of me.
You know what I mean?
I made my impression --
-You elected out.
-Yes, yes.
-You made another
elective choice.
-So I haven't been
to Spain since.
-Oh, that's great.
[ Laughter ]
So you both took the --
you both are making yourself
not fly the airline
or even go back to the country
after what you did.
-Yeah, I just figured
I should give the whole region
a break.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-That's very kind of you.
-Once you kind of
make that kind of impression,
it's good
to just take some time out
and then go back
when you can
make a new impression.
-Yeah, that's great.
Thank you.
It is always so lovely
to see you.
Congratulations on the show,
and best of luck
at the special taping.
Chelsea Handler.
Tickets to her
"Vaccinated and Horny" tour
available at
chelseahandler.com.
We'll be right back
with Martha Stewart.